one of the multiple definitions of trees
that we saw is that it's a minimum edge
a simple graph that connects up a bunch
of vertices and that leads to the idea
of finding a spanning tree within a
simple graph that maintains the same
connections so let's begin with a
precise technical definition a spanning
sub graph of an RF G is simply a sub
graph that has all the vertices of G so
again a sub graph of a graph means it's
got a subset of the vertices and a
subset of the edges spanning sub graph
is that it has all of the vertices but a
subset of the edges and the definition
of a spanning tree is a spanning sub
graph that is a tree now not all graphs
are going to have a spanning tree
because the tree has to be connected if
the original graph is not connected
there's no way you can find a spanning
tree using only the edges that are there
already but it's going to turn out that
if the graph is connected it's
guaranteed to have a spanning tree let's
look at an example here's a simple graph
and what I want then is a spanning tree
a selection of edges that connect up all
the vertices such that we're only using
edges in the original graph and there
they form a tree there it is so if you
check on these magenta edges that that
I've highlighted they define a tree I
haven't used three of the edges in the
original graph now this particular
choice of spanning sure is kind of
arbitrary in general there's lots of
spanning trees here's another one this
time with green edges again I'm using
only edges from the original graph I've
left out three different ones and used a
different set of edges to form the tree
but there it is
it's got no cycles and it spans the
graph because every vertex in the graph
is part of it and of course it's
connected since it's a tree okay there's
actually some lovely combinatorial
theory which enables you to calculate
the number of spanning trees in a simple
graph without too much difficulty just
given its adjacency matrix but we're not
going to go into that for now okay um
first remark is that every connected
graph is going to have a spanning tree
and the reason is you just pick a
minimal edge
tree so minimal edge connected spanning
sub graph rather so G itself if it's
connected is by definition a spanning
graph of itself because it's got all its
own vertices that means by the well
ordering principle there's going to be a
connected spanning sub graph with a
minimum number of edges and that one
given that it has a minimum number of
edges it's guaranteed to be a spanning
gray a spanning tree okay now the
problem gets more interested when an
interesting one has a little more
structure of instead of just trying to
find a spanning tree that has a minimum
number of edges it's quite typical in
applications that the edges have weights
and we want to find a minimum weight
spanning tree so here's an example where
we have a simple graph with a bunch of
edges and a bunch of vertices and the
edges all are assigned in this case an
integer weight now the motivation for
this kind of graph is you could think of
these weights on the graph as indicating
the cost of transporting some quantity
commodity from this vertex to that
vertex directly by a road or the time it
takes to transmit a signal over this
channel there are lots of ways that that
simple graphs are used to model issues
of communication among various locations
and it's quite typical that the channels
and connections between them have
different costs and it's a natural
question to say ok what's the minimum
cost overall tree structure that will
enable me to have everything connected
to everything else in the same way but
that I can tolerate some of my edges
going down and I still would like to
have the cheapest kind of tree that
spans them all all right well there's a
fairly simple way to construct such a
minimum weight spanning tree and that's
what we're going to talk about now how
do you find it well the idea is to build
it using gray edges so what that means
is that starting off with the vertices
we're going to start building a tree and
at any point we will have a bunch of
edges that are going to be part of our
spanning tree that means that the edges
don't have any cycles among them
there are so called forests but they're
not yet connected and at each stage in
this procedure we're going to look at
the connected components of the graph
that we have at this moment and color
them black or white and then look at the
gray edges so a gray edge is defined to
be an edge where one endpoint is black
and the other endpoint is white and what
I'm gonna do at any stage in the
procedure as I'm growing my spanning
tree numb and white spanning tree is I'm
gonna look at all the gray edges and
pick a minimum white gray edge well
let's do an example to get this clear so
to begin with I don't have any edges oh
I have are the isolated vertices so it
means that I have six connected
components each of which is a single
vertex with no edges okay um that says
that I'm allowed to color them black and
white in any way I chose um and I will
do that the only constraint on the
coloring is there has to be at least one
black component and one white component
so there's an arbitrary colouring I've
colored two of the vertices white and
the other four black now in this
particular coloring I could have chosen
any one but I chose this one um where
are the gray edges well I've highlighted
them a bit by thickening them so this is
a gray edge because it's black and white
um this is a gray edge because it's
black and white black and white black
and white um this is not a gray edge
because it's white and white this is not
a gray edge because it's black and black
so that's a simple enough idea and now
what I'm supposed to do is among my gray
edges pick the one with a minimum weight
well if you look at the weights of the
gray edges I got a for a for a nine a
seven and a 2 the two is the minimum
weight gray edge I'm gonna choose that
to start building my tree okay so at
this moment once I've committed to that
magenta edge what I now have is a graph
with five components namely the
component defined by this edge with two
vertices and the other four isolated
vertices which still don't have any
edges connecting them in the structure
of magenta edges that I'm building to be
my minimum spanning tree so according to
the rules now with these five components
I can recolor them and as long as I
recall er them in a way that this
component gets the same color there's a
recoloring I've made both of those
vertices in this component black and the
other four vertices which are isolated
components I can call her arbitrarily so
here's my new colouring now again once I
have this coloring I can proceed to
identify the gray edges there they are
and this time there are only two gray
edges because I chose to have only one
white vertex there's a gray edge and
there's a gray edge and of course the
minimum weight among the two gray edges
is three so that's gonna be my next edge
in my little minimum weight spanning
tree that I'm growing what's next
well now I have four components left
here's one component defined by that
edge here's another connected component
defined by that edge and these two
vertices are isolated still so that
components all by themselves and the
rule is recolor in such a way that both
of these vertices in that component have
the same color all the vertices in this
component have the same color I could
switch them from black to white in fact
I will and those can be colored
arbitrarily let's do that there's eerie
coloring now this component is all white
that component is all white these two
separate components happen both to be
black and as long as I had I could have
called one of them white and one of them
black I need to have one black given the
other commitment to colors okay so now
again we could find the minimum weight
edge a gray edge I guess it would be
there are two ties for minimum of both
of those ones and I proceed in this way
and I wind up with this minimum weight
spanning tree that's the procedure now I
haven't discussed why it works yet and
that is explained in the notes but we're
going to hold off on that and just
examine applying this algorithm so there
are a bunch of ways now to grow a
minimum weight spanning tree
one way is to start at any vertex um and
then start keep building around that
vertex so you start with that vertex and
color it black and everything else white
well and that means that all the gray
edges are going to be connected to that
vertex so pick a minimum white one now
you have a component with two vertices
color it black and everything else white
and in that way you keep working on one
component that you're gonna grow by
always coloring it one color and
everything else the other color this is
a method known as prims algorithm for
growing a minimum weight spanning tree
another one is to globally among all the
different connected components find a
minimum weight edge among them so what
that means is that you find the minimum
weight edge among all the the connected
components and then having identified
where that minimum weight edge is you
can color one of its components black
and the other one white and that will
cohabit conform to our procedure for
picking a minimum weight edge between
different coloured components that's
kruskal's algorithm and finally you can
grow the trees in parallel well you can
just start choosing the minimum weight
edge around each connected component
because you can always take a connected
component color it one color and color
while the other edges another color and
so all of the edges touching a given
component will be gray in that color and
you can choose the minimum one and grow
that component and if they're not too
close to each other so that your choice
of engines doesn't conflict you can grow
these trees in parallel so I call that
jokingly Myers procedure and that is the
application of this coloring approach to
finding minimum weight spanning trees